Broadly speaking, a cult is a group or movement...
...with a shared commitment to a usually extreme ideology...
...that's typically embodied in a charismatic leader.
Most cults share some basic characteristics.
A typical cult requires a high level of commitment from its members...
...and maintains a strict hierarchy,...
...separating unsuspecting supporters and recruits...
...from the inner workings.
It claims to provide answers to life's biggest questions...
...through its doctrine, along with the required recipe for change...
...that shapes a new member into a true believer.
And most importantly, it uses both formal and informal systems...
...of influence and control to keep members obedient,...
...with little tolerance for internal disagreement or external scrutiny.
A modern cult, by contrast, separates its members from others.
Rather than providing guidelines for members to live better lives,...
...a cult seeks to directly control them,...
...from personal and family relationships...
...to financial assets and living arrangements.
Cults also demand obedience to human leaders...
...who tend to be highly persuasive people...
...with authoritarian and narcissistic streaks,...
...motivated by money, sex, power or all three.
The cult environment discourages critical thinking,...
...making it hard to voice doubts...
...when everyone around you is modeling absolute faith.
The resulting internal conflict, known as cognitive dissonance,...
...keeps you trapped, as each compromise...
...makes it more painful to admit you've been deceived.